good morning Hank it's Monday progress
okay today is the last day I can make
meaningful changes to the Fault in Our
Stars and no offense to you but I don't
want to spend the day with you I want to
spend the day with the books because
it's our last day together all right
hold on I got to go talk to the medical
librarians of Indiana I'm only gonna do
take a few things just ignore it I've
lived with this thing for four and a
half years now um I think I just made a
good joke about I'm on steroids to sign
all the books and I don't know if I can
get in the Guinness Book of World
Records because it's like technically
like performance enhanced signing it was
funnier the first time I respond medical
librarians are so nice Hank okay Hank I
have to go back to the Fault in Our
Stars but I'm not leaving you high and
dry instead I'm giving you a truth or
fail specifically one about animal
mating so that's nice of me
the Tippie odometer is going to go down
a little bit because I filmed this in
the past but yeah enjoy so Hank I will
see you on Wednesday but now I test your
knowledge of animal mating with a truth
or fail hello and welcome to truth or
fail the YouTube game show today we're
going to do it like they do it on the
Discovery Channel and talk about animals
and their mating habits that's one
giraffes just kidding there will be no
giraffes the rules here are simple I
give you two purported facts you either
click on the true one or you fail it's
just like a regular gameshow except
instead of playing for prizes you are
playing primarily to learn things that
you wish you could forget about animal
mating however one person chosen at
random who finishes the game will
receive a signed copy of one of my books
so alright let's get right to it here
your first set of facts fact 1 the
desert grassland whiptail lizard is a
species of clones the population is
entirely female and they sell fertilize
their own eggs so each offspring is a
clone of the original or fact to the
male red-sided garter snake is so rare
that females must copulate with any
males they come across and usually that
is either a father or a brother alright
so which is it going to be you need to
click on one of those over there do you
believe in the incestuous garter snakes
or do you believe in the terrifying
attack of the clones whiptail lizards
it's time to make a choice you just
click unless you're on an iPod in which
case you can't play this game because
annotations don't work I'm sorry go to
your computer ok it's weird the mobile
taking everything over just go to your
computer by the way do you like the suit
I dressed up because it's about animal
sex all right click or you are going to
fail you have like 5 4 3 2 1
fail